un laboratoire de 6000 mètres carrés des
bureaux administratifs 9 ou encore de
nouvelles machines
un investissement total de près de 8
millions d'euros pour rémy tech
cette entreprise créée en 1989 est
spécialisée dans les tests de produits
des équipements grand public à
l'industrie aéronautique automobile ou
médicales elle réalise près de 35
millions de chiffre d'affaires par an
nous avons aujourd'hui des voitures
électriques des voitures hybrides des
véhicules communicants des véhicules
intelligents de plus en plus
d'électronique donc de plus en plus
d'essais à réaliser nous avons investi
des cages de faraday spécifique à
l'électronique automobile
au total et mitec a investi dans huit
nouvelles cages de faraday pour
augmenter la capacité des essais en
compatibilité électromagnétique des
ondes de sont envoyés sur l'objet
électronique testé pour observer sa
réaction
on peut avoir par exemple sur un produit
un peu complexe un arrêt de
fonctionnement si on prend une
télévision
la télévision va se brouiller et donc on
peut pas permettre quand une mobylette
passe dans la rue que la télé ce bruit
autre type d'essai la résistance à des
vibrations des chocs ou encore des
secousses des tests liés aussi aux
conditions climatiques réalisé dans ces
huit machines acquise dernièrement pour
un montant total d'environ 300 mille
euros cet ensemble permet de tester les
produits en fonctionnement au world
fonctionnement dans des températures
hautes ou basses puisqu'on peut
descendre à moins 80 moins 100 degrés et
monte à plus 150 en fonction des
machines vraiment tester les équipements
dans tous les
les environnements possible cette
société saint-quentinoise dépend de la
capacité des entreprises à innover
depuis le début de l'année 2018 et mitec
a réalisé près de 20% de croissance